what's up this is Tom Segura and I'm
doing the wired autocomplete interview
we're all over the place man
why does Tom Segura speak Spanish I have
a mother who speaks poor English she's
from Peru that's her native country she
came to the United States when she was
30 and she knew like eight words of
English my whole childhood she spoke to
us in Spanish I learned Spanish by
having a relationship with my mother why
does Tom Segura
glove is that a sentence who's typing
these okay I think I understand this I
don't know this might I might be wrong
on this on my podcast I one day showed
up with one glove I mean this is really
stupid but I think stupid bits are the
most fun to do I would put one glove on
and if somebody pissed me off I go you
get the glove like that and it's it's
the dumbest thing people really
responded to it and they were like oh
he's got the club and then I'm at
shows now people throw gloves on stage
so I'm assuming this is that question or
this is somebody who just arrived in the
country and is trying to get a grasp on
the language but that's why I glove why
is Tom Segura why is Tom segura's wife
called push good question uh that's 100
uh Bert Kreischer Bert is a fun guy frat
dude and there's one thing about frat
dudes is that they love nicknames I
don't think he calls anybody by their
real name and he calls Christina push
because her last name is pajitzki
but he would call her pushitsky he's
like oh push how's push doing it's 100
from Bert it's his nickname for her
what Tom Segura
what is Tom Segura what is Thompson's
Starbucks order great question it has
changed over the years I would say for
the last year it has been the Nitro cold
brew but check this out I have a few
modifications in a venti cup with some
ice and a splash of oat milk it's not
that crazy and it's not that complicated
and don't roll your eyes at me
okay it's pretty simple and if it's too
much for you to do then you shouldn't
work there and I've been to a few where
they go oh we're not allowed to do it
and I go yes you are and unless you want
this place to turn into a war zone
you're going to make it right now what
yeah he passed away isn't that crazy I
mean I don't but there's so many ways
this can go you can say he evolved he's
doing much better now he's back he's
still here I don't know what happened I
think I'm a work in progress and what
happened is it where I think we're in a
good place right now I think things are
actually this is a good time for me that
question is going to hurt in like 11
years though
what the times we're gonna do before
comedy I worked in post-production on
reality shows I was a logger which uh
sounds like I'm hauling wood through the
forest but what it means is that you
type everything said on the raw footage
of a reality show it is absolutely
mind-bending work I was a
post-production coordinator I worked in
a pizza shop I was a site rep which
means that you would show up to a
building and just make sure that
production people didn't destroy it like
these guys did here today yeah I did
those until I was making enough to
support myself as a full-time stand-up
which I would say took about nine years
before I didn't have to have any at
least side work what did Tom Segura
say to Andrew
yeah I had Andrew huberman on two bears
one cave he was a guest it got millions
of views and millions of downloads
fascinating really good dude who happens
to be a brilliant professor and I
said a joke that he was like that is not
okay you have to cut that and I did and
here's the thing that I tell people who
ask me will you tell me what the joke
was I go no because it's his to tell I
said it but he asked me to take it down
therefore it is his to share what is the
best Tom Segura
special this changes for everybody it's
like asking people their favorite movie
from a director their favorite album
from a band there is a time where you're
just you are just getting better at what
you do so I feel like they're actually
in in kind of the order they get better
as each one comes out
when did Tom Segura let's see here start
comedy I started comedy in 2002. I have
it on tape I've never watched it maybe
I'll put it out soon I'm sure it's
pretty bad when did Tom Segura
get famous my first special came out on
Netflix in 2014 and it's called
completely normal and that definitely
changed my touring life and then with
each subsequent special it increased
podcasting became much more popular and
so it's just been kind of year by year
which I think is probably the better way
to get some type of uh recognition from
people it's probably better than an
explosion of popularity and I mean after
this interview
I'm probably gonna be way more famous so
when is Tom Segura next Netflix special
is that grammatically a sentence learn
English but it's called sledgehammer and
it comes out Fourth of July so go out
have a few drinks blow off your dad's
fingers when you get home from the
hospital put on sledgehammer
oops sorry here we go ew is Tom Segura
that is a question that I'm always
trying to answer myself I'm a father
I'm a husband
I'm a son I'm a brother I'm a comedian
and I'm just trying to make it through
this life I'm no better than you
I'm just a lot funnier and I do a lot
more cool than you do that's it
it's the only difference who is Tom
Segura touring with I try to make my
shows not just hilarious shows but fun
shows for me both on and off stage so I
bring my friends I bring gray Comics
Jeff Tate Kirk Fox Matt fullstron Ryan
sickler Ryan Simpson I bring people that
are Josh Potter like that are super
funny and fun to be with and that's what
makes a great tour who does Tom Segura
look like
I mean I don't know depends what year
there's my Artie Lang years people are
like you you know who you look like Zach
Galifianakis I'm like yeah because we're
chubby with a beard I don't know I mean
it's always just whoever's more popular
with a beard and then they go that's how
you look like
was Tom Segura in military which
Thompson are you talking about my dad
that was Tom Segura retired Marine Corps
Captain Tom Segura this time Segura was
not technically in the military but I do
wear my Oculus and I go into combat
regions pretty regularly I've talked to
a lot of guys who say that pretty much
counts so when I'm boarding a flight and
they say active military you can board
now I think that's the green light to
get on first was Tom Segura on SNL no
never been asked truthfully would love
to what's up Lauren was Tom Segura a cop
no I just have this face
and haircut and I look like that guy's
definitely a narc ever since I was a kid
people have been like are you a police
officer like when I was 14 they were
like you are undercover right Tom Segura
Tom Segura Jennifer Aniston I was doing
two bears one cave the podcast I do with
uh Bert Kreischer I made up a story that
my agents asked if I wanted to do a
movie with Jennifer Aniston I said yeah
of course I'd be interested and that she
wanted to pitch me the movie directly
and then at the end of the story I told
him that I had made it up and he was
really upset and then he said do you
think we could meet do you think she
would meet with us and I'm like yeah I
guess that's possible and then we
started talking about what it would be
like to go meet her at one point he said
can she bring a dude to the meeting and
I go yeah for safety you know she needs
to protect herself when she's with us
and he laughs so hard that it we just
both started crying laughing and it the
clip went viral and then she reposted it
she shared it and uh she sent me a
message being like I thought you know
you and your fat friend are so funny
Tom's a girl Quentin Tarantino I had
Quentin Tarantino on the podcast I'm a
huge fan and this is what a crazy thing
is that he had a book coming out they're
like oh he wants to come on and I go oh
I would love to have Tarantino on two
days before he comes on his agent sends
me a message says Hey the book is coming
out I don't know if I have time to get
you a copy of it he ends up shipping a
copy of it to my house the day before I
do the podcast so like one day earlier
and I'm like oh great but we come in you
know I have it and we're talking on the
podcast he tells me stories he's like no
one's ever asked that question I've
never told this story before it's an
awesome awesome time towards the end of
the podcast I bring up something about
the book he's like yes that's what I'm
here to talk about and I'm like oh right
right he goes how far are you on the
book and I'm like I'm I don't know
pretty far I say something he's like
that's like the third page and I'm like
yeah and he's like so you didn't read
the book I'm like I got it yesterday
dude it's really cool you to have me on
and like I thought he was kind of upset
about it and I was like damn he goes why
didn't you read it I'm like you guys
sent it yesterday day like what do you
want me to do Tom Segura going to the
bank I mean I'm doing pretty well is
that what this is about I think that
might be a reference to a bit where um I
talk about going to the bank the guy
that works there wrapping me into one of
the most boring conversations of my
entire life where he took me saying how
you doing literally you know like I mean
it like how you doing and like the
courtesy is to be like all right how you
doing like that's the exchange you're
looking for with the door guy at the
bank and this dude I go how you doing he
was like my sister she's in Virginia and
I'm gonna go see her next week and I was
like what the are you doing right
now he told me a whole story about his
upcoming travels and I wanted to stand
in traffic Tom Segura hologram I was
absolutely mesmerized by this Whitney
Cummings is a great comic and a producer
and she put together a roast of my buddy
Bert Kreischer and I couldn't make it
and she was like oh I'll just send a
crew to your studio and you can do your
set on this latest and greatest hologram
I thought it was going to look like oh
like sort of a rough image like what you
imagine a hologram was kind of from 20
years ago Dude it looks like I am
standing in the room it is actually
terrifying Tom Segura Kid toilet water
again a bird story where her Crusher
came to my house my six-year-old was
five at the time he had a cup of water
he goes here you go got you some water
and Bert was like okay
thanks he goes drink it but it was like
oh where'd you get it he's like from the
sink Bert goes well if you have some
first and he goes no it's for you and
Bert's like did you get this like knot
from the sink and he goes no he goes did
you get this from the toilet and my kid
goes no and I'm sitting there watching
this and I go hey did you get this from
the toilet he goes no and I turned to my
friend I go I believe him and then he
goes I don't believe him and he won't
take it and my kid keeps going like so
at the time I go all right I just walked
to the bathroom I see a trail of water
from the toilet all the way out to where
he is and I go hey don't drink it don't
drink and I go out there and I go hey
man you got this from the toilet and he
goes I'm sorry and he just walks away I
was like man I have a couple little
psychos how did Tom Segura
and Bert Kreischer meet doing stand-up
the first time we met I believe was in
2003 or four I have to look but it was
at the Brea Improv in Brea California I
was the MC like the first guy the host
of the show he was the middle act and
Jay Moore was the headliner and that's
when I met Bert Kreischer super nice guy
uh he was much thinner is Tom Segura
alive yeah this at this moment I am you
know you can just go at any time
does Tom Segura do meet and greets new
not interested I don't like the
organized meet and greet if I'm walking
around yeah I say I hi to people I
always take anyone wants a picture like
I do all that stuff I usually am walking
in or out of venues and meet people that
way if you see me doing an organized
meet and greet where like you had to pay
money to do a meet and greet with me I
am in financial trouble does Tom Segura
have a kid yes I do I have two their
names are Ellis and Julian they're two
wild dudes I love them they're
absolutely fantastic kids they keep
waking me up that's why I look like this
people are like how come you look tired
I'm like because I am dude they come in
at all hours I go get out of
here get out of my room they're like
okay and then they come right back and
they tell me a story and like it's
four in the morning man I'm
losing my mind
I very much appreciate all your
grammatically incorrect questions
there's a lot of wondering if I'm alive
feels like people
not really paying attention I feel like
you could just Google my name you
wouldn't have to go as far as is he
alive